[Music]
[Music]
you have absolutely mastered this game
well since um Sheila left I've been
spending a lot of time playing the game
you're doing really good yeah thank you
that's why we're here man help you get
over her and check out this awesome new
game you have you know I left something
in another room excuse me everyone
oh he still has the sensors on him in
his room is he on his knees does he drop
to his knee oh he's probably looking for
no like he's he's crying he's crying
he's just this is our feed oh yeah he
crewed up look at that he's feet off hey
Craig buddy you all right up there
hey man you all right yes yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah it's just uh my sinuses are
acting up yeah yeah I um I was just you
know I was just thinking about Sheila
and you know what I am totally over her
awesome that's eight let's get this
party started sure oh I forgot to get
rid of this picture Sheila excuse me hey
maybe leave the sensor so one of us can
play
oh he's dancing he's dancing with the
phone Oh is he he's doing he's doing
this about is he kissing it nice right I
think he's kissing it no I'm gonna turn
this off because we don't need to change
it and you die he's under a snorkel look
at this his pants are coming off his
pants are coming off oh god yeah no no
no no no okay that's happened oh no no
is he he's a he is totally on the bed
he's totally flat on the bed okay well
that's just oh God we shouldn't be okay
you know they see reaching down for
school no that's his foot isn't it is
that who I am sorry everybody
[Music]
would you like me to make some snacks
wash your hands first
[Music]
[Music]